dis maman des grandes maintenant je
crois que tu es prête
tu peux faire un tedx arrête tu sais
bien j'aime pas les écrans nous sommes
la première génération de parents à
avoir vécu avec les écrans moi je suis
une petite fille qui a eu la télé à 12
ans 12 ans sans télé sans téléphone sans
rien que les voisins les copains d'école
et jamais rien qui me connecte au monde
envahi en fait j'étais vraiment connecté
au monde mais plus commandes qui
déconnecte et aux arbres aux oiseaux aux
rivières ou marcher pieds nus dans
l'herbe
allez voir les lapins dans les clubs
quand j'avais un chagrin ça devrait
monter dans les clapiers des dates ans
je parlais avec les petits la propre
dette nette sans console est une espèce
de lenteur infinie
alors quand j'ai vu les jeux vidéo
arrivé dans ma vie je me suis dit ça
c'est du viol familiale je me suis dit
comment on va faire avec ce truc qui
aspirent les enfants plus que des
aimants cent mille volts un jeu vidéo et
vos enfants sont tranquilles
apparemment tranquille
nous ne savions pas faire nous n'avions
rien compris alors nous on a eu la
chance d'avoir quatre enfants et donc
nous avons expérimenté avec l'aîné et
malheureusement la quatrième a pas pu
trop expérimentée parce qu'on était féru
sur le sujet alors s'il faut avoir
quatre gosses pour arriver à gérer les
cheveux vidéo on est mal barré donc il a
fallu près de trente ans pour que nous
ayons enfin une codification de serge
tisseron autour des écrans nous avons
avant trois ans l'enfant a besoin de se
construire des repères spatiaux et
temporelle donc avant trois ans pas du
tout d'écran pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout je dis pas dit ça veut dire que
vous vous iphone vos téléphones et tout
quand vous êtes en présence de vos
enfants de moins de 3 ans in et off
fight la psychopédagogue et non pas
psychiatre psychopédagogue je vous dis
qu'aujourd'hui l'évolution de mon métier
je suis formatrice dans tout le secteur
de la petite enfance et je vois tous les
jours ce que je pressentais
intuitivement il ya trente ans je vois
les dégâts que ça fait aujourd'hui
trente ans plus tard y at il des gens
qui tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
personne pas beaucoup alors j'ai ma
feuille de pompe dans la poche
non je vais la prendre 1
mais qu a écrit sur l'impact des écrans
il s'appelle michel desmurget sophie de
xambes regarde la télé une heure par
jour cela double ses chances de
présenter des troubles attentionnels en
grandissant lubin trois ans regarde la
télé deux heures par jour c'est la
triple ses chances d'être en surpoids
kevin 4 en regard des programmes
jeunesse violents comme dragon ball z
c'est la craie quadruples ses chances de
présenter des troubles de comportement
quand il sera à l'école primaire
sylvia sept ans regarde la télé une
heure par jour
c'est là augmentent de plus d'un tiers
ses chances de devenir une adulte son
diplôme
lina 15 ans regardez dire des séries
comme desperate housewives se fait
lentement mon anglais c'est la triple
ses chances de connaître une grossesse
précoce non désirées entre 40 et 60 ans
yves à regarder la télé une heure par
jour
c'est là augmente d'un tiers ses chances
de développer la maladie d'alzheimer
henri 60 ans regarde la télé quatre
heures par jour
rené son jumeau se contente de la moitié
henry a deux fois plus de chances de
mourir d'un infarctus que rené chaque
mois des revues scientifiques depuis dix
ans publie publie public sur les dangers
de la télévision
la france comme prévention santé
s'alarme absolument pas la télévision
les écrans on nous dit même aller on
veut introduire les écrans à l'école les
enfants
inattention de regard inattention de
mouvement ils sont complètement sous
pression j'aime bien comparer la télé
les jeux vidéo et tablettes
et smartphones à une niche du chien on
attache les gosses on l'aimait pas grave
je pourrais faire ça je pourrais faire
ça je pourrais faire ça on s'en foutra
la paix cinq minutes c'est bien mais
quand on enlève la laisse le chien aboie
il a été attaché il bouge dans tous les
sens visart des enfants il devient hyper
actif
puis ils ont des 10 de parts ou
dyslexiques dyspraxiques décisive alors
déjà ils sont bien occupés ils ont pas
beaucoup de temps libre elle rend valeur
m orthophoniste orthoptiste si comme au
tri siens sip sip sip si donc c'est
parfait mais est-ce qu'on se pose la
question de coffrets ton à nos enfants
impossible sur écran de vivre les
réceptions émotionnel de l'instant et y
répondre par la compréhension de l'autre
notre corps notre âme notre cerveau sont
faits pour vivre avec les autres
c'est super important quand je dis
quelque chose je vais interagir
immédiatement par tous les messages
infra verbaux de l'autre c'est ce
qu'apprend le nourrisson dont les
premiers jours de lien avec sa mère
terry braselton nous la décrit avec une
infinie patience
comment je fais quand je suis sur un
écran pour comprendre que ça n'interagit
pas je dis quelque chose j'agis et ya
pas de réponse d'humains assumer la
réaction immédiate raw propos
dérangeants ou agressif en direction de
l'autre et en mesurer l'impact inhumains
ou violents je fais des conférences sur
le harcèlement scolaire
aujourd'hui nous nous rendons compte que
ça n'a plus aucun impact sur facebook je
peux poster n'importe quoi je crois que
je suis protégé dit d'impunité en disant
des choses extrêmement violent à l'autre
il faut qu'on chope grosse chute alors
brosse à chiottes il a juste une coupe
un petit peu sportive au dessus de la
tête un peu droite
en plus il a une couleur de cheveux pas
tout à fait conformes à la grande
majorité parce que dès qu'on sort de on
n'est pas comme les autres on va être
objet de harcèlement
l'endroit le plus violent et qui a
augmenté les harcèlements qui est plus
de 25% aujourd'hui à l'école c'est les
nouveaux moyens de communication
la campagne actuellement en france du
gouvernement pour faire un peu de
prévention est très éloquente et je vous
invite à aller la voir
écoutez c'est propre ressenti émotionnel
et les exprimer face à l'autre dans une
écoute empathique guéri sentent comment
je vais apprendre à l'autre à se mettre
en réception de moi et à exprimer ce
qu'il ressent lui est bien pour cela il
faut avoir traversé soi même des
émotions et quand je suis petit que je
fais de l'ecoute émotionnel je vais
apprendre à savoir sac c'est quoi qui se
passe en moi c'est quoi et c'est bien
dans ces ressenti émotionnel que je vais
pouvoir parce que je les ai ressenti
savoir qu'ils existent identifier la
tristesse je vais pouvoir être
compassionnel quand j'ai identifié la
tristesse
j'écoute la tristesse de l'autre je
réagis mentalement en imaginant que
cette tristesse de l'autre n'est pas ma
tristesse et quand j'ai compris que la
tristesse de l'autre n'est pas ma
tristesse
alors là je suis empathique et si j'ai
de l'énergie de vie pour changer le
monde et que je propose quelque chose
pour la tristesse de cette personne
alors là par amour
je deviens compassionnel la compassion
dit pierre rabhi au pays des colibris la
compassion c'est l'avenir
l'humanité donc si nous privons nos
enfants de tous est ressenti émotionnel
nous privons tout simplement l'humanité
de sa capacité à être en relation avec
les autres j'entends tout le temps que
l'altruisme est en train de disparaître
chez nos enfants nous sommes les
responsables de ce nous sommes nous
responsables de leur laisser ou de leur
enlever les écrans je préconise ce jour
d'éteindre les écrans entre 6 heures du
soir et 21h on met toutes en mode avion
et à ce moment là on peut faire de la
rencontre de la relaxation des douches
tipis des accueils aimant douche tipi
c'est quand on se rentre du boulot on
fait la douche où on enlève tous les
soucis du boulot ça marche vachement
bien exercer dans la relation à l'autre
les joies de l'altruisme dans les rires
les champs les contacts corporels
essentiel au vécu humain vivre la
sécurité des activités de faire seul et
en lire les résultats de l'expérience
comme unique jugement sans valeur
extérieure de notation de critères de
réussite sans jugement qualitatif ou
quantitatif les activités auto telle hic
les activités qu'on fait sans aucune
intention
les activités qu'on fait juste pour les
faire
grrrr les grelots combien j pierre
darmon sabots merci de vous
mme harel tricotin osselets élastique
bilboquet greli grelo toutes ces petites
activités où on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
un téléphone portable des parents pour à
38 soldats temps pour attendre dans le
bus on a le droit de faire des choses
toutes simples on peut ramasser des
cailloux dans
ru fr grigolo éducation consciente
non-violente jeux symboliques motricité
libre toutes ces activités dont je suis
la servante défense riis depuis 30 ans
et qui aujourd'hui sont portés par plus
de 30 % de parents nouveau créatif qui
ont décidé de prendre en charge le
bonheur de leurs enfants en proposant
une éducation différentes pédagogies
alternatives les grands mâts les grands
responsables les grands pdg aujourd'hui
de la silicon valley préconise
l'éducation pour leurs enfants
steiner freinet montessori sans écran
les mecs ils ont cru le truc
ils en connaissent tous les tenants et
les aboutissants ils savent exactement
que c'est absolument pas confortable
dans la durée et bien voilà ils nous
font ce team ans cadeau de nous dire
c'est mieux sans je suis inquiète pour
l'enfant de demain et plein d'espoir
toutefois l'imagination est vraiment
quelque chose de nécessaire pour
l'enfant l'imagination le faire dans
l'instant présent faire du jardin se
promener jouer à les faire toutes les
activités manuelles possibles et
inimaginables être là ici et maintenant
présents avec leurs parents dans un
contact affectif dans les bras être avec
les enfants
autrefois quand on n'avait des enfants
qui étaient plus ou moins polissons eh
bien on leur disait simplement tu viens
avec moi toute l'entente prend 1 j'en
prends un vauban les calmer ses gosses
aujourd'hui on leur met une tablette
dans les mains pour les apaiser
non le contact corporel est la voie de
la paix la plus grande dans la relation
à l'autre
les enfants aiment naturellement la vie
personne ne leur apprend cet amour il ne
peut être enseignée seulement vécu
si tu vis cet amour de la vie hilton en
non en raison de qui tu es mais en
raison de qui ils sont à ce merveilleux
chanteur lucarne à qui j'ai été enlevé
la console de jeux vidéo à ses 16 ans
pour lui donner à la place une guitare
et qui aujourd'hui honore sa maman sur
scène en faisant des chansons absolument
merveilleuse si ce jour là j'avais pas
éteint la console il ne serait pas lui
je dis simplement que le courage d'être
parent aujourd'hui c'est aussi détaché
nos enfants de cette chose qui est si
difficile la mise à distance des
nouveaux moyens de communication
j'avais tellement peur de le faire dit
lily tu penses que j'ai été à la hauteur
communiquez avec joie amour
ce que j'aime faire depuis si longtemps
parce que la communication avec les
êtres
c'est avant tout un bonheur d'être
ensemble
je suis ainsi pas autrement je ne suis
pas quelqu'un qui membres par mon
silence et mon sourire je dis bien ce
que je veux dire je ne suis pas
quelqu'un qui charme pour cacher la
cause des larmes je dis ce que je crois
vrai et si je le dit fort c'est exprès
je viens vous dire qu'il faut vivre au
temps et mieux que dans les livres
je suis ainsi pas autrement votre vie
est mon élément par tendresse par amitié
je suis
je reste à vos côtés